في تطور اخر اعلنت بهجين وموسكو صباح
اليوم عن موعد زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا
بين العشرين والثانيه والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري بدعوه من نظيره الروسي وقال مساعد
الرئيس الروسي ان الرئيسيين سيناقشان
الصراعات اوكرانيا معربا عن تقدير موسكو
لموقف الصين بشان الازمه واضاف مساعد
الرئيس الروسي ان جزءا كبيرا من تقييم
الصين للاوضاع في اوكرانيا يتوافق والرؤيه
الروسيه حسب تعبيره وذكر الكريم انه في
اطار المحادثات يعتزم الرئيسان بحث تطوير
الشراكه الشامله والتعاون الاستراتيجي
وسيوقعان على عدد من الوثائق المهمه
وسبق للرئيسين الصيني والروسيه ان التقيا
في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي على هامش قمه
منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون في اوزباكستان
واكد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
قد قال ان زياره الرئيس الصيني المقرره
الى روسيا بين العشرين والثاني والعشرين
من الشهر الجاري تاتي لي تعزيز التنسيق
الاستراتيجي والتعاون المشترك بين البلدين
خلال زياره الدوله التي سيقوم بها الرئيس
جيمينغ لروسيا سيتبادل الاراء بشكل معمق
مع الرئيس بوتين بشان العلاقات الثنائيه
والقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام
المشترك وتعزيز التنسيق الاستراتيجي
والتعاون العملي بين البلدين كما ستدخل
زياره زخما جديدا في العلاقات الثنائيه
في خبر عاجل ورد قبل قليل ويظهر على
شاشتنا اعلنت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
اصدار امر اعتقال بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين
ارتكاب جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا
قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
واشنطن لن تدعم وقف اطلاق النار الذي
ستطالب به الصين في اجتماع موسكو لان من
شانه ان يخدم روسيا واضاف في تصريحات بشان
الزياره المرتقبه للرئيس الصيني لموسكو
انه يامل ان يتواصل
مباشره
كي يسمع منه ولا يكتفي بوجهه نظر بوتين
فقط وشدد كيربي على ان وقت اطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي لن يؤدي الى
سلام عادل وان الولايات المتحده تريد
انتهاء الصراع بما يحفظ وحده اراضي
اوكرانيا واتهم كيربي روسيا بانها تريد
استغلال اي وقت لاطلاق النار من اجل تعزيز
قوتها والسيطره على مزيد من اراضي
اوكرانيا
وفي تعليقه على زياره الرئيس الصيني
لموسكو قلم متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان واشنطن تراقب عن كسب زياره
الرئيس الصيني لروسيا ونقلت شبكه سي ان
الاخباريه الامريكيه عن المتحدث قوله ان
بلاده تامل ان يستفيد الرئيس الصيني
وحكومته من دعمهما لروسيا لتاثير عليها
واوضح البنتاجون لشبكه سي ان ان بلده لم
ترى ان الصين قدمت اي نوع من المساعده
الفتاكه لروسيا لاستخدامها في ساحه
المعركه في اوكرانيا ونقلت سي ان ان عن
مسؤولين امريكيين ان واشنطن تعمل على
ترتيب اتصال هاتفي بين الرئيس الصيني
ونظيره الاوكراني
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
ومن واشنطن مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي
والبدايه معك وجد لماذا
تستبق واشنطن هذه الزياره وتضع نوعا من
الشروط وكانها تريد ان
تحد من قدره الرئيس الصيني على النقاش في
روسيا
يعني هي ليست شروط حسن بقدر كونها رسائل
ترسلها الاداره الامريكيه لكل من بيجين
وموسكو قبل هذه الزياره الاسبوع المقبل
للرئيس الصيني ولقائه الرئيس بوتين
الرسائل كانت واضحه الولايات المتحده
تعتقد بانه لا ينبغي للصين ان تستمع فقط
الى وجهه نظر روسيا والرئيس بوتين وتكتفي
بها هي حتى الان لم تتواصل مع كييف منذ ان
بدا الحديث عن احتمال وساطه صينيه ومنذ ان
اصدرت الصين قبل اسابيع خطتها ذات الاثني
عشر بندا من اجل احلال السلام في في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي كل اتصالاتها كانت خلال
تلك الفتره فقط مع الجانب الروسي ولم
تتواصل بحسب الرئه الامريكيين ولو مره
واحده مع الجانب الاوكراني لتستمع الرئيس
زيلنسكي ما هي احتياجات اوكرانيا القضيه
الاخرى الرساله الثانيه التي اراد كوربي
ارسالها هي ان هناك بند متعلق بوقف اطلاق
النار ضمن هذه الخطه ذات الاثنتين عشره او
الاثني عشره
اذا تم بالفعل
الضغط باتجاه وقف اطلاق النار بالوضع
الحالي فهذا يعني تلقائيا الاعتراف بضم
روسيا للمناطق الاوكرانيه الاربعه التي
ضمتها الى اراضيها في اقليم الدومباس
وبالطبع هذا الامر مخالف لما تريده
اوكرانيا والرايسكي وايضا بالتالي الاداره
الامريكيه اللذين يعتبران بان هذه اراضي
اوكرانيه وبسببها بدات روسيا هذه الحرب من
اجل يعني الاستيلاء على تلك الاراضي
باللغه بحسب الوصف الامريكي كذلك بالنسبه
للصين الولايات المتحده تعتقد بان الصين
تحاول اعطاء الانطباع بانها صانعت سلام في
حين ان هذا السلام اذا تم بالخطه التي
قدمتها فلن يكون عادلا ولن يكون دائما لان
هذا يعني قدم اراضي اوكرانيه لكن السؤال
هنا المطروح في في موسكو عما سيبحث فعلا
الرئيس الصيني وما الذي تامله روسيا من
هذه الزياره امين
لا يحصر هذه الزياره في بحث الملف
الاوكراني بالرغم من انه موضوع رئيسي في
اجنده المباحثات المرتقبه الاثنين
والثلاثاء المقبلين بين الرئيس الصيني
ونظيره الروسي هنا في موسكو اليوم مساعد
رئيس الروسي يوري اوشاكوف وضع الملامح
البارزه والمهمه لاجنده هذه المباحثات
التي قال بانها ستتطرق في بادئ الامر الى
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه التي وصفها بانها
الافضل في تاريخ العلاقات بين البلدين بين
موسكو وبيجين اضافه الى موضوع الطاقه
التعاون العسكري وايضا العلاقات التجاريه
بين البلدين في ظل التحديات الراهنه
المتعلقه على سبيل المثال بالعقوبات
المفروض على روسيا وايضا في اطار الازمه
التي بدات تظهر بوادرها ازمه اقتصاديه في
عدد من الدول لكن طبعا عندما يصف اوشاكوف
هذه العلاقات بانها علاقات متوازنه ذات
مصالح مشتركه بين البلدين ليس فيها زعيم
او تابع بحسب فوسفيف فهنا يبدو انه شكوف
يرسل يعني اشارات واضحه ورسائل واضحه الى
العلاقات التي تنتقدها روسيا في الجهه
المقابله وتحديدا العلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها خاصه الدول الاوروبيه
خاصه وان الجانب الروسي في الفتره الاخيره
يحاول وضع مقارنات بين العلاقات التي او
المستوى الذي وصلت اليه العلاقات بين
موسكو وبجيم من جهه
والعلاقات بين الولايات المتحده وعدد من
العواصم الغربيه على راسها
الاوروبيه على سبيل المثال بوتين قبل ايام
انتقد بشده
السياسات التي تنتهج المانيا خاصه فيما
يخص الملف الاوكراني اقل بانه ليست هناك
اي استقلاليه في اتخاذ القرارات وهذا
لربما سيكون من ضمن عدد كبير من المحاور
والسياقات التي سيبحثها الرئيسان طبعا
زياره مهمه جدا زياره تاريخيه هي الاولى
للرئيس الصيني منذ اعاده انتخابه اول
زياره خارجيه ويبدو ان الجانب الروسي كما
الجانب الصيني طبعا يعولان كثيرا شكرا على
نتائج هذه المباحثات شكرا لك
وشكرا لوجد وقتي من واشنطن